Thank You chair thank you for this
debate we we agree we very much agree
that crack we should be very concerned
about crimes against journalists and
impunity for such crimes wherever
wherever that is taking place but in
particular as many of you have
underlined we also have to focus on our
own countries the European Union because
these things do happen on our own
doorstep and as a number of you are
underlined a free media a media where
journalists can report on any topic on
all platforms without needing to censor
themselves is a cornerstone of our
societies and indeed that journalistic
freedom of expression is a key part of
the values that we seek to defend in our
European Union so the points that you
have raised including some of the new
detailed points that have been raised
are very important to us I set out
briefly some of the things that we're
already doing and planning to do but we
will now study very closely some of the
additional suggestions that you have
raised and this subject will be a key
subject for the new commission taken
forward by my colleague Commissioner
Yuri over who would have very much like
to be with you this evening
this is one of the subjects that she
holds very close to a heart and you can
count on her to pursue it vigorously
thank you very much and now madam on
behalf of the president say madam
minister to Perrine into fluorescence
madam president honourable members thank
you very much for your very important
interventions let me assure you once
again that the presidency and the
council as a whole is committed to the
fight against impunity for crimes
against journalists the freedoms of X
and the breasts enshrined in the EU
Charter of Fundamental Rights need to be
current age in all Member States and
those who will fall victim to crimes
must receive justice the killing of
death Negara ionically here proves that
no region of the world is immune to such
crimes we reiterate our commitment to
combat impunity for crimes against
journalists and country and to continue
using all appropriate means possible to
respect and to protect freedom of
expression and to ensure the safety of
journalists and media workers and the EU
already provides financial and expert
support for human rights defenders and
mininum media monitoring in the EU we
further
foster the protection of journalists
bloggers and media workers in many
countries with financial and expert
support and may I recall in mind that
media pluralism and the rights of
journalists are also an important aspect
of the rule of law which is a high
priority of the Finnish council
presidency we are tireless in protecting
the respect of the rule of law so we
will continue to watch very closely the
relevant investigations and we will
stand firmly behind shown our
journalists around the world I can
assure you that the council has taken
careful note of the views expressed here
today on this very important issue thank
you very much for this debate again
thank you very much madam minister and
the debate is then closed